- Grab out that shopping
list and get your pens ready
because time and talk presents people.
I wanna share some of the hottest gifts
you can give this year.
Oh elf come on out here.
(festive music)
I'm just gonna dance by
doing a little body roll elf.
That's what I'mma do today.
All right. How you doing?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, you're impressed
by... you're into it.
I get, I feel you, it happens.
Let's get...How you doing
- It's fine
- You doing good?
- Yeah it's fine.
- Is it cold in the North pole right now?
- No.
- No?
No.
- It's hot.
Hot today
- Yeah, hot today, all right.
Well, let's get started, here we go.
I love a hot North pole.
Here we go.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, this is glittery and great.
Great designs, fine jewelry
and engagement rings.
Features sustainably created
diamonds from their Foundry,
which is the only certified
diamond producer in the world.
Certified with net zero carbon footprint.
They carry unique diamond
shapes and recycled gold.
Like the diamond bezel necklace
which comes in 14 carat
yellow and white gold.
Pretty nice.
I like the layering.
I like that.
Okay, here we go.
We're doing the next one.
All right, let's see what
this next one is all about.
What do you think it is?
Do you know?
- Car.
You don't know?
Did you say you don't care?
(audience laughing)
Alright, some people sing
in the shower, like me.
Others are happier just
listening to the music.
The Moxie shower head by Kohler
creates a fully immersive experience
that allows you to stream your
favorite music or podcasts
all while getting a good rinse.
Or you can pop out the wireless speaker
and take your tunes with you on the go.
So that's pretty rad.
(audience applauding)
I'm gonna...I'll get this
installed in my shower.
I'm gonna have my own concerts.
Just by myself, just hanging out.
This is gonna be for you.
- I'm so excited.
- I feel like you need
a good night's rest.
- I can't wait
- Yeah.
Yeah, you making a lot of toys.
So maybe the best gift
we can all get this year
is a good night's rest.
Amen, hallelujah.
Can I get an amen?
(audience cheering)
Exactly.
Thank you.
Alright. Well, here we go.
This is...I'm short.
So hold on.
Yep. Five three and a half people.
There we go.
All right.
Cariloha is making a
difference in the world
through their ultra soft
bedding, clothing and bath goods,
made from sustainable eco-friendly bamboo
which is awesome.
One of our favorite products
is their bamboo mattress
which helps you comfier and cleaner
with its naturally
breathable moisture wicking
bamboo foam that improves air flow
to help you sleep even cooler.
I hate that.
When you...do you get cold
at night or warm at night?
- Yeah, I get hot all the time.
- I get hot and then I
have to find a cold spot.
Then I move to find the cold...
- I can't take this off and it's just hot.
- You never take it
off, you sleep in that.
- Yeah
- Well...
- It's hot all the time
- Kind of complaining about it.
You hate to be an elf.
- Yeah, it's true
- You're saying.
- Best job I've ever had.
- All right, well.
(Kelly laughs)
Plus it adapts to your body
shape, which is awesome.
Alleviating pressure off the
body's main contour points
to ensure a restful night's sleep.
So here's my point people,
today, in our house seats.
Who in our house seats
could use all of this.
(audience cheering)
Who wants this?
That's what I...
(audience applauding)
I don't feel that.
I'm just gonna say I'm gonna
give one each of these gifts
to the one person showcasing
the most dazzling jazz hands.
Let's see those fingers
waving and wiggling people.
She wants it.
(audience cheering)
Alright, well you are
all it so you know what?
You are all getting
everything you see here;
the Vrai necklace,
moxie shower speaker
and cariloha mattress.